hey guys what's up this is andrew from
trendsenses.com so in this video i'm
here guys to make a huge update on amc
uh nothing much happened this week in
terms of
levels we are still close to the 40 area
but actually there is a lot of
information to get from it so let's get
into it
[Music]
all right guys so very quickly daily
timeframe one two three four five elliot
waves guys this is what we're looking
for one two three four so it seems we
are in the false triangle wave which is
typical for force wave and we are trying
to predict whenever this is gonna start
to move higher strongly so to do that we
need to find a breakout trend line and i
have one by connecting the highs here in
logarithmic scale very important to be
in logarithmic scale you can see that
this trendline is working well because
it's giving us reactions all right
whenever your trend line is not perfect
you just move it slightly to make it
perfect golden rule the most recent past
is the most important that's why here i
need to to have this point into account
and here i just moved my trend line
because of this rule alright so here we
had some excess at the beginning the
trendline was like this okay and here we
have this excess so i kept it like that
at the beginning you can see that here
it gave me a positive reaction but right
now i prefer to have it like that okay
so it's arguable it's my choice i prefer
to have it like that okay so what is the
situation we have a b c d e okay so the
e wave is it here is it here are we
going to revisit the lower band of the
triangle i don't know it's possible
but usually e-waves are in three ways so
first thing so abc so did we have an abc
here or is the abc going to be like that
i don't know how to say but we have some
hints
first let's analyze closely this price
action what is happening we got rejected
first we moved lower
how low
okay around the 61.8 retracement of this
move which is you know a normal
correction below that it's not looking
good it's it's a bit losing the bullish
momentum so here we didn't really lose
it and we went higher right away
re-tested twice the next week then we we
found support on the 20 and 50 day
moving average just like i showed you
guys in my yesterday's gme video on gme
you can see we didn't even touch it and
this was meaning the bears were not able
to reach the targets and it was
suggesting that both were strongly in
control on amc we are touching it so we
are staying above so bulls are in
control but
you know we were not that bullish on the
short term as we were on gme and this is
what i was telling you guys in my
everyday recaps for free on discord for
amc and gme every day i give you my view
and so here we are bullish because we
are above those moving averages which
doesn't mean we cannot uh go lower we
can like i said have an abc like this
and it would be fine as well so it's not
my preferred scenario this is the
alternative scenario so i can give it to
you right away we go here
okay we found more support and then
breakout retest and we go higher
alternative scenario my preferred
scenario is look at jamie so jimmy broke
out already same triangle so jme it's
been you know already sometime i'm
saying that is a step ahead because here
my triangle is done
since august and to me we have completed
one two and we are in the third wave why
are we in the third wave on gme because
we have those very impulsive strong
moves that go through major resistance
levels this is the definition of third
wave so that's why i believe this is the
third wave amc is not to me in has not
started its major fifths this one and
now and you guys know that those two you
know they they move together so
sometimes the flows go from one to the
other uh i think that right now people
are going to be focused on jamie at the
beginning of the week maybe still amc is
probably gonna follow okay if jamie for
example moves up by 20 amc is gonna move
up as well i don't know about how much
but
what i'm convinced off is that if jamie
confirms you know this move up so by
closing above 230 for example amc would
have no other choice than doing the same
at some time so then even if we don't
have to break out to me
it's a buying opportunity whatever the
price i mean you know what i mean if
jamie is there amc will catch up so i'm
gonna keep an eye on jimmy to trade amc
and once again like i said i was a buyer
around this area if we close above 44 45
i'm gonna add up to my position and if
jme closes above 230 i'm gonna add up as
well whatever amc's price okay
so this is the way i see things so my
preferred scenario yeah is this i'll
just show you that is that jamie pushes
higher maybe pulls back a little bit so
imc is probably gonna test the 44 level
maybe consolidate a bit more and then
move higher okay and one more thing why
did we have a lot of information even if
nothing happened because look guys as i
did for gm yesterday let's check how
much energy amc has so to check the
energy you have two different tools you
have more than that all right but there
are two tools that i like to use on my
hand bollinger bands bam and rsi so
let's check whenever they are tight it
means that the volatility decreased for
around two weeks and it gives energy so
here they were tight here
after that we had a move down and now
they are not tight not wide all right
because here it moved a bit so i would
say we are medium in terms of energy so
no real information and the second thing
you can do is just by looking at the
bands we are medium and the second thing
you can do is look at the rsi and the
rsi
for example on gme we are close to the
overbought normal it's normal because we
just had a huge run up so that's when i
think the gm needs to take a breath soon
either at 230 or at 250 very quickly but
amc is in a totally different situation
it's
it has an rsi at 50. so to me we are
looking we have energy to break out okay
so this is good so if we have a breakout
now it's much better than having a
breakout on that day because on that day
we were having evil if even before the
move up we are having rsi around 65.
okay right now before we move up we have
another side 52 so neutral so that means
that whenever we're gonna break out we
still gonna have some energy to push
higher why because we had this build up
phase why build up because some booze
are building up some long position and
the market is building up energy right
you can analyze this world by
those two different ways
so basically to me
those consolidation period of low
volatility which is not very low here
that's why the bollinger bands are still
a bit wide are some very important
phases for the market to build energy to
be able to break out and push higher so
the fact that we are here hovering for
the past two weeks around the 40 level
right between roughly 38 and 44 so 41
level even
is very good we're building up energy so
basically we are building a bull camp
just below the breakout area all right
so bulls are gathering there more and
more bulls are coming and suddenly one
of them i mean it's not exactly like
that but they're all gonna start to buy
more volume is gonna increase and things
are going to look better so this is my
view now let's quickly check the
synthetic shots as usual guys i'm
keeping an eye on the 145 strike last
time there were 20.2 million shares gets
instantly short
okay here we go so first amc dtc is the
most important thing basically stable
slightly lower after the option roll
because november has expired people are
going to roll on the next maturities for
now they didn't roll everything they had
for this reason the dtc is slightly
lower the maximum synthetic short has
dropped a little bit as well the
synthetic shot has dropped as well so
everything has not been rolled yet so
let's see what happens this week i'm
pretty sure that a lot of buyers will go
to the option market if they feel a
breakout might come soon so i'm gonna
keep an eye on that it's important so
for now i would say mutual information
nothing very bullish because not
everything has been rolled but it's not
bad news either because it's always like
this after maturity so no information
from that and 145 strikes still growing
20.5 million shares all right guys keep
that number in mind and we're gonna
check that again once again for those
who are watching that for the first time
the more options we have on those very
out of the money strikes the
tougher it's going to be for option
market makers whenever we're going to
get close to that because they're going
to be short gamma which means that short
delta the short exposure is increasing
on the upside especially when we get
close to this levels so if we get close
to it there is a high probability we go
through it that's why what it means and
the way i see it
so once again you know that my target is
135 you know how i found this target i'm
going to show you that again quickly
i'll just use feed projections the exact
same thing i was doing in the past and
that worked very well in may so we're
doing the same up we applied to the
bottom of the force and it gives us 137
something like that but when i see this
huge
huge number of options on the 145 strike
it makes me think that if we get 235 we
might maybe have a quick run up to do
200 area or something maybe 170 i don't
know something like that and then new
strikes are going to be open and we're
going to need to check if people go to
it if for example they open the 250
strike and everybody rolls from 145 to
250 i would need to reconsider my target
for now this is not what we're having my
target is 235 but i start to think that
maybe it's a bit low but for now i keep
that target because this is the best i
can give you guys by using my tools so
that's it for today i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button so you're gonna be the
first to know when i upload anything new
and stay close to show i'll see you guys